no secret I'm holding it a fart it's
destroying my insides hey what is going
on YouTube now I don't go on Facebook as
often as I should but every now and then
I'd like to go on Facebook to catch up
on my friends lives why don't you shut
the [ __ ] you know what I realized some
people are too damn into their feelings
on Facebook you know what people I'm
talking about right you filthy attention
[ __ ] and you ever notice that every
time they post something emotional it's
usually about their relationship and
it's never straightforward it's always
just enough information so that we know
that you're sad about something booger
tits but just enough so we ask what's
wrong so let's talk about some of those
posts there's the we know you're talking
about your boyfriend but now we're not
sure if you're together or not and that
post usually sounds something like this
sometimes when you hit that point it's
just better to let go first of all
riddler what the [ __ ] are you saying
either one you're talking about leaving
a man or two you're constipated and you
need to take a serious [ __ ] which is it
how many times do you put up these type
of posts on a regular basis it's too
much because it's never just once we
don't need to know every time you and
your dumbass boyfriend or girlfriend
break up [ __ ] you break up with that
boy more than you sneeze [ __ ] you break
up more than a teen breaks out [ __ ] you
break up more than Jesus breaks bread
and usually right after this type of
person writes this post what do they do
they either delete it right after
because they're embarrassed this bug
because they got right back with them or
suddenly the dude that broke your heart
and told in your titty look like a flat
Jack with a racist cup stuck right in
the middle two weeks later he's your man
crush Monday and in that man crush
Monday posts you write [ __ ] about him
that was the exact opposite of what you
said in your Facebook post he is my rock
my foundation and why I better myself
every day
shut the [ __ ] up do you realize how
unstable and stupid you look to us on a
regular basis you see most people try to
hide the fact that they're crazy from
their peers but you tell the people that
one you can't commit to your life
choices two you have terrible taste in
men or women three things aren't real
for you unless you tell people or create
drama or you were dropped on your head
as a baby listen nobody's telling you is
that okay for you to feel the way you
feel about your personal relationships
but the moment you put that [ __ ] out to
the public [ __ ] it's a free-for-all why
do you always have to post it on your
facebook about your temporary feelings
it's okay to think through things and
then keep that [ __ ] to yourself do you
know what they call you in the Chinese
community a big bow [ __ ] so before you
go ahead and post 14 times a [ __ ]
month all the times you're broken up
with your boyfriend and your girlfriend
just remember nobody wants to see that
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
you